اهلا بكم في مؤتمر انا اسمي علي عبد
الرحمن عندي ثمان سنوات في الصف الرابع
النهارده احكي لكم حكايه حلوه قوي قوي قوي
قوي من صغري ما بحب الحيوانات جدا
وانا مره والعب بتمساح اللعبه لقيته ماما
فجاه تقول
بابا
وبعد كده وبعد كده بحثنا في الجوجل عشان
نعرف الفرق ما بينه وما بين البرص وعرفت
عنه ومعلومات مذهله جدا
بس برضو عرفت ان هو مهدد بالانقراض كنت
اول مره اعرف الكلمه دي يا ترى يا اصحابي
مين يعرف معنى كده
انقراض يرفع ايده
ايوه صح انقراض يعني حاجه تختفي الارض
واكتشفت اكتر عن الحيوانات والطيور
وبقى عندي صديقه مميزه جدا اسمها ضحى كنا
بناكل وبنشرب وكمان بنقرا
وكمان بنقرا
بس انا رحت حدائق الحيوانات لقيت حيوانات
عيونها حزينه
وكمان كنت كل مره اروح الاقي واحد منهم
ناقص
الاقي واحد منهم مقص
انا بحلم انا لما اكبر ان ما يكونش في اي
حدائق حيوان وتكون كلها محويات وبس
الكون كلها وحياته بس
الطبيعه روان لازم نحافظ عليها
وننقذ الحيوانات المسرده زي حاتم 60
ونكته روايات عن عن
زي ما رياض عجوز
وكمان عرفت ان الحيوانات تروح زينا لازم
نرحمها لازم نرحمها وتفرح وتزعل وكمان
بتغضب ليه الحديقه الحيوان نعل المحميات
شكرا يا اصحابي على مشاركتكم ليا
[موسيقى]